as president zielinski prepares to
deliver his virtual speech to congress
in a couple of hours from now cbs news
has learned that the u.s will provide
another 800 million dollars in security
assistance to that war-torn country
president biden is expected to make that
announcement a little bit later on today
nancy cordes has more from the white
house nancy good morning to you
good morning gail president zielinski
actually released a video this morning
thanking president biden for the
billions of dollars in aid so far but
president zlonski's speech to congress
and the nation in just a few hours is
likely to put more pressure on president
biden to take some military steps that
he does not currently support
a three-minute standing ovation from
canada's parliament yesterday after
ukraine's president speaking remotely
begged them to support a no-fly zone
over his country
[Music]
how many more cruise missiles have to
fall on our cities he asked until you do
this and make this happen
zelensky is likely to repeat that
request when he speaks to the u.s
congress today
but the biden administration has already
rejected a no-fly zone and zielenski's
plea for more jets warning that those
moves could draw the west into direct
confrontation with putin the president
believes that any
effort to help the ukrainians
is potentially
provocative to the russians
look the provocations already occurred
the president did sign a bill tuesday
granting 13.6 billion dollars worth of
humanitarian economic and military
assistance to ukraine we're managing to
get supplies in ukraine regularly thanks
to the bravery of so many front line
workers with sanctions pushing russia to
the brink of default the country tried
to hit back yesterday imposing sanctions
on 13 well-known americans including
hillary clinton who mockingly thanked
russia for the lifetime achievement
award also on the list press secretary
jennifer sackey defense secretary lloyd
austin and joseph robinette biden
president biden is a junior so
they may have sanctioned his dad may he
rest in peace
these new sanctions are unlikely to
impose much of a burden they freeze the
russian assets of the 13 individuals on
the list though it's unlikely that they
have any and they prevent the
individuals from traveling to russia
which is something that most americans
aren't doing right now anyway gail
all right nancy cordes we thank you